donald trump has hinted that the saudi
monarch
wouldn't last two weeks if it wasn't for
the u.s military the u.s president made
that fiery assessment at a campaign
rally in the u.s state of mississippi
but wouldn't give any specifics about a
conversation he had with the saudi king
which
he referenced in his speech we protect
saudi arabia would you say they're rich
and i love the king king solomon but i
said king
we're protecting you you might not be
there for two weeks without us
you have to pay for your military
our u.s correspondent samira khan joins
me now samira thanks for uh
joining us so we're able to delve any
deeper perhaps into that comment from
president trump what exactly he meant by
that statement
well we can guess but considering the
arms deals and pulling out of the iran
deal
it's clear that the u.s considers saudi
arabia to be a major ally and
if you remember about a year ago trump's
first foreign trip was
to saudi arabia but trump's latest
remarks show that there could be
some a growing contention between the
two
trump's been trying to get a saudi
arabia and opec
to lower gas prices but some have said
that this is trump's way of securing his
party's control
in congress rather than a genuine
concern about
high gas prices but the intention hasn't
been made clear yet
but i wouldn't hold my breath